alors en termes dans les cinq dernière
question malheureusement sans sentir ici
c'est vraiment drôle alors là on en est
à votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
a jamais de gros mots de la semaine
bon sang de bonsoir tir alors moi c'est
chamelle c'est le joueront qu'en projet
mon grand père quand il taper sur les
doigts chat mais la femelle du charmant
oui si tu mets timsit timsit c'est le
vôtre gros mots et moi c'est les siens
de trou du cul tu manges tu es mort à sa
douce des zones où le culte amer moment
j'étais mort oui c'est bien l'inversé
millions cabut alors c'est sacré et
soirées passées ça
homme ou femme pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque
cabu un billet avec mathis ne serait pas
mal ah oui ça serait joli
ah bah là on vient d'en parler justement
les nouveaux penseurs ben focaux
sabatier les les gens on se tourne
aujourd'hui les plus populaires le
docteur de thierry lamy parce que c'est
un type formidable seront pas content là
bas c'est pas sympa dynastique mais
sera-t-il vraiment eu étonnant
gainsbourg gainsbourg moi ce sera un
côté mesrine sur un billet mais de le
coter ravachol avec lui qu à ce jour
pour les grosses coupures alors le
métier que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
princesse monégasque a loupé
moi je suis pour j'avais écrit imprimé
vidangeurs ou alors critique littéraire
ouais faire le mickey chez euro disney
oui vendredi membre du csa
je trouve ça vulgaire oui membre du csa
oui femme au foyer
parce que c'est un métier veulent dire
qu à but militaire
évidemment oui militer à ça c'est sûr et
la plante la roue l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné n'importe
quelle plante carnivore
bouffer oui c'est ça une plante
carnivore il bouffe le pen le tabac
tabary doit pas pourquoi parce que c'est
agréable de le regarder pousser après ça
sèche et puis c'est pas mort en fait on
en profite à presse existe tout le temps
il ya les pour y aller contre n'en parle
pas ou souhaitent faire attention à ma
fille ça va être l'herbe et un plant
d'herbe
un plant d'herbe il peut plus blairer 9
dur un oeuf dur un oeuf dur tiennent un
bouledogue antoine de france est avec
moi n'importe quel animal domestique
pourvu qu'ils appartiennent à ornella
mutti bah oui c'est sûr et en finlande
et la question si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire vous n'êtes pas
beaucoup vu à la messe alors heureuse et
les lieux pardon alors heureuse
alors heureuse oui enfin euros on a
préparé une petite réception pour vous
j'ai eu courrières volta je vous
présente renoir truffaut hergé il ya eu
bourrage me soient légaux et permet sa
fille vas-y moi je prends la moche
si on récuse merci enfin qabus ben ils
diraient tu as choisi le canard enchaîné
et la grosse bertha tu t'es trompé tu as
perdu
eh ben c'est pas ce que vous espérez
c'est le pari de pascal parce que vous
espérez entend devenir un hamastan jt
sur la barre et où je prévois toujours
le pire arrive hermida s'est tout de
suite après l'acteur est choqué
[Musique]